[WHOOSH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INTERVIEWER: Why did you
want to become a firefighter?
SUBJECT: I wanted to become
a firefighter because I
saw these guys as superheroes.
I saw these guys as
bigger than life.
And it wasn't until
I got into the job
that I realized that
we are just human.
I've seen more in one
day than probably someone
has seen in their whole life.
INTERVIEWER: What kind
of things do you see?
SUBJECT: I see faces of death.
I see old people,
young people, kids.
There are images that
are hard to erase.
And it doesn't hit
me until I get home
that I can't fix
someone's death.
I can't fix someone
who is broken.
I can't fix these
things in my head that
make me feel like I'm crazy.
Who talks about that?
The only time you see
a firefighter crying
is when one of
their coworkers die.
OK.
INTERVIEWER: Can you
tell me about one
of those times when you
weren't able to save someone?
SUBJECT: I went on a call where
the young girl in her early 20s
was partying on top of
an apartment building.
And she fell and tumbled and
hit the sides of the walls
and was killed.
But she still had signs of
a little bit of life in her.
And I was the person
doing compressions on her,
but I didn't realize later
on that this event was going
to send me into a tailspin.
Some of these calls
just mess you up.
And this call messed me up.
I wanted to start
drinking so I'd
mask these feelings
and these emotions.
And it didn't help.
I would use prescription
pills only because I just
wanted to get numb.
INTERVIEWER: You were diagnosed
with post traumatic stress
injury-- PTSI.
Can you tell me about that?
SUBJECT: I'm healing
from my injuries.
I'm not going to be
completely healed,
because I just went on a call
last week that messed me up.
But I get through them quicker
because I'm not drinking.
I'm eating cleaner
and stair-climbing.
INTERVIEWER: Tell me how
you go from using alcohol
as a means of escape to
climbing stairs as a new ritual.
SUBJECT: Using drugs and
alcohol you get high.
Doing stairs I get high.
I try to get in
10,000 steps a day.
And mentally, it's
a great escape,
because you're able to
really get out of yourself.
I've begun to realize that
I'm trying to control things
that I have no control over.
I'm trying to control death.
You can't control death.
So I focus on
trying not to think.
I focus on just trying to get
myself upstairs the stairs.
And I just focus on
just being positive.
I started organizing
my coworkers
to join in and do this
climb as a tribute
to the guys that
were killed in 9/11.
So now we start wearing gear.
We start wearing our bunker
pants and our firefighting
boots, and we wear our helmets.
And you get to a point
where you just want to quit.
And then I think about the
people who cannot do this--
the people who aren't
here anymore, you know.
The stairs are a
metaphor to life.
Just one step at a time.
All that excitement,
energy, sweat,
tears is contained until you
get all the way up to the top
where you just like explode
and just feel like the sky
open up to a feeling that
everyone should experience.
And I think that a
lot of people think
that they can find
that in a pill
or at the bottom of a glass.
They don't have go there.
And then when you're
able to really get
that big breath of fresh air,
you're breathing in life.
It's amazing.
INTERVIEWER: Next
on Seeker Stories,
the ritual I developed while
captive in North Korea.
Click now to watch.
It was the scariest
time of my life.
I was isolated in
what is perhaps
the most isolated
country in the world.
But there was
something that I began
to do that helped me
get through each day.
And it was a very simple act.
Rituals is a part
of Seeker Stories.
If you'd like to
continue to see more
stories from around the world,
we need you to subscribe.
[WHIR NOISE]